what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight death prediction video I know a
lot of you have been asking me to make
this video so I figured I would give
some my early predictions about which
characters I think will die in the final
season before any real spoilers or
photos come out let me know which
characters you think will die down in
the comment section and we can see who
gets the most right after season 8 ends
this video will only be part one of my
list of characters that I think will die
and I will release a part two video with
more characters as soon as possible just
a quick reminder to those of you that
don't know I am doing a new giveaway and
since some of you didn't watch my last
video I'm gonna tell you about it real
quick I'm giving away three prizes to
three different winners the link to
enter the giveaway will be in the
description of this video if you click
that link you will find out how to enter
and what you can actually win if you
decide to participate keep your eyes
open for any new video I post because
I'm gonna start announcing a different
winner in a different video within the
next 30 days
alright now let's get started with the
predictions my first prediction is sir
Jaime [ __ ] Lannister and I know
plenty of people who hate this character
but I have to be honest with you Jaime
Lannister has grown on me ever since
season 3 this was a man I hated with the
passion during season 1 & 2 but I have
grown to love this character although he
still has some issues with him the
reason why I say this is because I do
not want Jamie to die I would like to
see him live some sort of normal life
after it's all said and done but I just
don't see this character surviving the
great war he has pretty much lost all of
his ability to defend himself
in fact he should have died a few times
already but he has been lucky enough to
stick around ever since he lost his hand
he has lost his legendary sword fighting
skills and now he is heading north in a
place where not too many people like him
I do think Jaime will be accepted into
Winterfell when they will allow him to
fight with them but I don't see anyone
other than maybe Brienne being willing
to stick their neck out to save Jaime if
he gets into some trouble in the
battlefield I'm not necessarily saying
anybody's gonna let him die because
they're gonna need his help no matter
what but let's just say I don't see
anybody willing to take a bullet for him
other than Brienne the knight King and
his army are making their way south and
before you know it the north is going to
be completely
under attack and everyone in John and
Danny's camp will eventually be
surrounded by whites and white walkers
in my opinion I don't see Jamie making
it out of this alive he may still find
an opportunity to kill Cersei but I
think Jaime will die in the Great War
and he will die in the arms of the woman
he loves just like he said he wanted it
but the woman that he loves is not going
to be Cersei which is who he meant at
the time when he said that but he will
actually die in the arms of Brienne
that's how I think Jamie's story's going
to end but and this is a big but I think
Jaime will die by actually sacrificing
himself for one of the Starks possibly
bran Stark but if it's not a stark whose
life he saves then I think it could be
brains
I see Jaime dyin in one of the most
honorable ways possible which is
sacrificing himself so others can live I
don't think this is something someone
could really imagine Jaime doing back
when he was a cocky handsome man of the
Kingsguard but since this story began
with Jaime pushing brain out of the
window I think his story will end by
saving one of the Starks
also after Jaime dies I believe Brienne
or someone else will make sure Jaime's
pages and the white book get filled with
some of the deeds that he has done and
will do in the future Jaime Lannister
someone forgot to write down all your
great deeds but still time is there for
a forty-year-old night with one hand how
can you protect me with that I used my
left hand now your grace makes for more
of a contest
after the Great War is over someone will
make sure that it is written in history
books that Jamie didn't murder the Mad
King for no reason but he did it to save
the city and they will make sure that it
is known that he sacrificed himself
during the long night the next character
that I believe will die is grey worm
I actually thought grey worm would die
in season 7 because they kept typing up
his relationship what Masson day and all
the promos and trailers so I assumed
they would kill one of these characters
once they got everybody invested in
their relationship but of course both of
these characters were pretty much put on
the sidelines midway through the season
I also think grey worm will die in the
north fighting the army of the Dead grey
worm has always felt sort of like an
expendable character to me but even more
so in the last season grey worm has
never fought in the north before he has
never fought in the freezing
temperatures with the ground covered in
snow and I don't think the unsullied or
Dothraki are going to fare very well in
the northern terrain I do think my Sande
will survive the entire series but I
think she's going to do it without grey
worm they will probably show these two
characters connect one more time right
before he goes into battle and then they
will tear another relationship apart by
killing one of them and I think that
person will be great worm I also think
the entire Nights Watch will cease to
exist - and I made a video specifically
about this before but I will briefly go
over my thoughts on this again basically
we're gonna lose at least half of the
remaining characters that are left in
this series and some of the first people
to go will be the type of characters
that will no longer be needed in the
final episode or I should say during the
rebuilding phase the dream of spring
phase I think the night King and his
minions will be stopped for good this
time they will be completely defeated
and they're not gonna go to sleep under
the ice again for thousands of years
they will be extinct which means there
will no longer be a need for the Nights
Watch the men of the Nights Watch were
meant to protect the realm from
everything that lies beyond the wall but
after the Great War is over there will
be nothing left to protect everyone from
north of the wall the wildlings and
other tribes are already either south of
the wall or dead and once the night king
and his army are dead then there will be
nothing north of the wall that anyone
will
really have to worry about anymore they
technically wouldn't even need to
rebuild the wall because I don't think
the others are gonna be pushed back up
north this time like I said I think
they're gonna be going for good the wall
and the Nights Watch will no longer
serve its purpose and from now on they
will have to throw their criminals in a
jail cell
no more running to the wall and joining
the black I think this will also be a
part of the new Westeros - things are
not gonna be done exactly the same as
they were before and getting rid of the
Nights Watch will be one of those things
no more barriers keeping people out of
the Seven Kingdoms Jon Snow has already
made sure that and I think this will
continue after the Great War next on my
list is another one of my favorite role
players good old beric Dondarrion and
let's be honest here barrack has been
living on borrowed time for multiple
seasons now this man should have died
six times already
in fact he's already dead in the books
dead for good - he sacrificed himself to
bring lady Catelyn back to life as Lady
Stoneheart
and obviously they never did this in his
show but Barrack will die at some point
and I just hope they let him go out in
style hopefully they will allow him to
use his ability from the books and give
someone the last kiss don't just kill
Barrack off like he's some
run-of-the-mill character give it some
finesse if it were up to me I would have
him die by giving the last kiss to
another major character I think that
would be a cool way to send him off and
it could be another nod to the books but
once again this is just my opinion that
is something I would like to see happen
if they decide to bring him back into
the story again and then ultimately end
his story
speaking of beric Dondarrion the next
character on my list is tormund
Giantsbane and it actually hurts me to
say this because torment is in my top
five favorite characters of all time
I've loved this character ever since he
was introduced even when he was
technically the bad guy I would hate to
see tormund die and they damn near broke
my heart in the finale when the wall
came crashing down at Eastwatch it
didn't look good for barrack and torment
but I'm hoping they can avoid being
killed as the dead marched through the
wall I need to see torment in the Great
War kicking some ass but I'm afraid he's
gonna die in the end even the
showrunners Dayne and Dave said either
torment or Brienne will die and
obviously they could be trying to
mislead people but basically what
happened was somebody asked them about
torment and burying and hooking up and
they said one of them must die in the
end
they will not live happily ever after
together and I think if one of them is
to die then it would be torment Brian is
arguably one of the best fighters left
on the show and she definitely knows how
to defend herself and she has a Valyrian
steel sword so she could defend herself
against the White Walkers as well I
think Brian will survive the entire
series but she will lose both of the men
that are in her life because Jamie and
tormund will die torment was lucky
enough to survive the mission beyond the
wall and he was lucky to survive the
wall coming down but I think the third
time will be the charm three strikes and
torment is out the next character that I
think will die is Sir Gregor Clegane the
motherfunking mountain I have no way to
put this philosophically or poetically
this [ __ ] just needs to die I don't
care if he dies during cleganebowl or if
he slips on a banana peel someone must
take this man down there is no way they
can let him survive this entire series
this freakshow has been wreaking havoc
since the first season and in my opinion
he will see his Judgment Day in the
final season
doesn't matter it's not how it ends for
you brother you know is coming for you
you've always known
you can't have the hound deliver a
bone-chilling line like that to the
mountain and not give us some kind of a
payoff he must pay for what he did to
another one of my favorite characters
Oberyn Martell I am still keeping my
fingers crossed for cleganebowl but if I
had a second choice it would be Arya
Stark
she still has him on her list and she
hates the mountain and I would love to
see her take this big man down if the
Hound can't do it on his own let me add
one more character to this list for the
part 1 video then I will get out of here
and since I am already talking about the
mountain who is in King's Landing let me
just slide right on over to Cersei
[ __ ] Lannister the Wicked Witch of
Westeros I think I can speak for 90% of
the fan base when I say we can't wait to
see this evil twisted brother loving
[ __ ] drop dead sir seize time is up
she must die and once again I really
don't care who does the deed but if they
want to make it extremely satisfying
then she needs to be killed by Jaime or
Tyrion or dare I even say Sansa now I
know Cersei is on arias list and Arya
really wants to kill her but I think it
would be more satisfying if Shawn's ax
was able to kill her instead of Arya
Sean's had to put up with Circe's
evilness way more than Arya ever did and
I would be extremely satisfied if songs
I was able to cast her down somehow but
I think Jaime or Oriya is actually more
likely to deliver the fatal blow but
there is a strong chance that Cersei
will live until the very last episode
considering all of her enemies are now
in the north and they are about to be at
war in the north since the night king is
already south of the wall John and Danny
are gonna have to focus on him
immediately which allows RC to continue
living unless that is of course someone
decides to take a quick trip to King's
Landing and finish her off
even if John and Danny's forces are
completely decimated by the night King I
still believe they will have enough left
over to take care of Cersei into whoever
she may have fighting for her in the end
then someone's gonna need to slip behind
enemy lines and most likely choke the
life from her and end her reign for good
comment down below and let me know what
you think of my list do you agree with
any of them or do you disagree and think
someone on my list will survive at all
let me know because I am anxious to get
some feedback on this one and like I
said this is only part 1 there will be a
part
- - this video soon and I will list all
of the other big remaining characters I
have left once again if you're
interested in the giveaway I'm doing the
link will be down in the description of
this video just follow that link there
is three prizes and there will be three
different winners and I appreciate those
of you that have participated already
thanks for stopping by everybody and
watching today's video I appreciate that
as always and I must thank all of my
patreon supporters as well and a big
thanks to all of my new patreon
supporters that I got this week it truly
means a lot to me I hope you all have a
great day and I will see you in the next
one bye
you